[Musique]
dernier numéro de l'entretien politique
consacrée aux élections régionales et
départementales sur tv à 78 merci de
nous rejoindre je reçois aujourd'hui a
dit annaba diop bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes tête
de liste ile de france
en commandant les yvelines aux côtés
d'audrey pulvar porte parole de la
candidate également et du parti
socialiste
audrey pulvar qui a lors de son dernier
meeting s'est donné un objectif arrêter
arrivé en tête de la gauche dimanche
soir à l'issue du premier tour
la campagne a été plutôt difficile
aujourd'hui elle est plutôt à égalité
dans les sondages avec julien bayou
juste devant les les insoumis est-ce que
arrivé en tête c'est un objectif
réaliste que vous vous êtes fixé oui
c'est un objectif réaliste
il faut rappeler que au tour d'audrey
pulvar elle a réussi à rassembler
plusieurs forces de gauche dont le parti
socialiste mais aussi le parti radical
de gauche les écolos solidaires nous
avons aussi place publique le mrc ou
encore les ou encore la gauche
républicaine est socialiste je crois
qu'elle est celle qui incarne
aujourd'hui le rassemblement
elle est celle aussi qu'il ya la mesure
la plus importante celle qui justement
incarne cette écologie sociale dont nous
avons tant besoin à savoir la gratuité
des transports mise en place
progressivement pour tous certains
épisodes pour être même laissé des
traces je pense à la question des
réunions mixtes pendant la campagne à
l'unef pour votre candidate il était
possible d'accepter des étés non blancs
à condition qu'ils ne prennent pas la
parole elle a aussi tendu la main vers
clémentine autain pendant que l'un de
ses principales soutien à anne hidalgo
elle critiquait jean luc mélenchon donc
rassembler tout le monde derrière tout
ça ce sera difficile non ce ne sera pas
difficile parce que pour ceux qui ont
suivi le débat hier soir on a vu qu'il y
avait de nombreuses convergences que la
gauche de toute façon cette grande
famille avec de nombreuses convergences
et bien plus qu'il n'ya de dix ans il y
avait effectivement des différences nous
affirmons par exemple que nous voulons
de faire des transports en commun un
service public et donc comme c'est un
service public nous voulons le rendre
gratuit pour les usagers à la fin du
mandat sur les six en nous affirmant
aussi que la démocratie représentative
c'est à dire les élus ne veut pas se
faire sans une démocratie participative
c'est pour ça que nous voulons aussi une
assemblée citoyenne du nom
terme ça veut dire que il faut que les
franciliens les français lorsqu'ils
s'expriment leurs voix ne soit pas juste
entendu mais qu'elle compte c'est à dire
qu'elles puissent accompagner pendant
tout le mandat
les décisions que nous allons prendre et
nous les prendrons avec eux si audrey
pulvar n'arrive pas en tête dimanche
soir
est ce qu'elle se rangera derrière une
autre liste de gauche évidemment mais il
y à deux conditions enfin la condition
c'est que la gratuité des transports par
exemple n'est pas négociable
ça c'est une des mesures sur lesquelles
nous ne renoncerons pas mais je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas de sujet puisque nous
arrivons en tête dimanche soir à gauche
et je pense à cette question de la
gratuité des transports vous dites c'est
non négociable
prenons en faisant un peu de politique
fiction audrey pulvar n'arrive pas en
tête cette question de la gratuité des
transports vous ne rêvez pas vous mettre
d'accord
quitte à perdre quitte à perdre cette
élection il y aura deux candidatures de
gauche trois candidatures de louche non
je pense que de toute façon nous serons
d'accord pourquoi parce que cette mesure
de la gratuité des transports il faut
quand même rappeler à nos à nos
adversaires et aussi aux autres
candidats de gauche et que lé publicité
par cette francilien sur dix sept
francilien sur 10
je pense que ce type de mesures ne peut
pas été ignoré par par les personnes qui
veulent faire de l'écologie sociale et
qui veulent faire de la justice sociale
donc nous sommes très sereins nous
savons qu'il ya un chemin
et ce chemin c'est de celui que nous
tracerons c'est celui du rassemblement
autour justement d'idées fortes autour
de la gratuité des transports de
l'assemblée stand du long terme mais
aussi de maisons de santé de proximité
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
oui parce qu'on parle de la question des
transports qui occupe beaucoup les
débats qui a beaucoup occupé les débats
et c'est assez logique en fait l'une des
compétences les plus importantes pour la
région ile de france il y en a d'autres
aussi
parmi les autres mesures récemment
audrey pulvar évoqué aussi une banque
publique d'investissement pour la
conversion écologique et l'emploi local
ça consiste en quoi ça consiste en fait
à donner la possibilité à nos commerces
de proximité mais aussi aux
auto-entrepreneurs à toutes les
personnes qui veulent investir dans
notre région d'avoir le soutien de la
région mais nous voulons que cet
investissement soit dans le sens de la
transition écologique c'est-à-dire
investir dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui est sous-exploité dans
notre région il faut savoir que
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est
quoi
c'est de l'emploi non délocalisable ça
veut dire aussi que on permet à des
personnes qui sont les plus éloignés de
l'emploi de s'en rapprocher
j'en veux pour preuve par exemple
l'association et qualys qui le fait elle
notamment à conflans sainte honorine
j'avais visité un de leurs ateliers et
c'est vraiment un des leviers les plus
importants que nous voulons mettre
service de toutes et tous pour
transformer notre région parlons des
yvelines aussi vous êtes tête de liste
dans ce département pour ces régionales
quelles priorités pour le département
aussi stand département très différent
il ya des zones très urbaine des zones
très rurales aussi et la région doit
veiller à englober tout le monde tout à
fait on vous l'avait rappelé il faut
savoir que notre région et notre
département plus particulièrement et
celui où il ya le plus d'inégalités vous
avez aussi aussi bien des des espaces
très ruraux comme le vexin ont encore
derrière mantes-la-jolie et puis par
ailleurs des des poches beaucoup plus
urbaines comme les mureaux dont dieu
dont je suis aussi une élue il va
falloir travailler justement à ce que on
est la rénovation de nos lycées
travailler sur la formation de notre
jeunesse
on l'a dit investir pour nos chronos
commerce sortent aussi plus renforcée on
sait très bien que la crise économique
va laisser des traces
assez importante des maisons de santé
pour se soigner
mais il faut aussi accompagner par
exemple usines renault qui doit être
dans une transformation nécessaire de
son activité mais se dit ceci ne doit
pas se faire au détriment des emplois
donc nous conditionneront les aides par
exemple aux grands comptes
justement à la qualité du dialogue ce
soit lé là sociale à la pérennisation
aussi des emplois il faut accompagner
justement ces employés vers une
transformation de leur métier pour
qu'ils soient justement performant mais
qui ne soit pas aussi les grands oubliés
de cette transformation écologique
suite à la crise sanitaire est aussi une
grave crise économique sociale
beaucoup d'entreprises ont été aidés par
là
région malgré tout elles seront elles
vont être si elles ne sont pas déjà en
grande difficulté dans les prochains
mois vous imaginez aider à éponger les
aides qui ont été versés par exemple
c'est ce qu'a proposé valérie pécresse
si elle est élue de d'annuler certaines
dettes et a dit ont été versés nous
accompagnerons en concertation
évidemment tous les commerces et tous
les auto-entrepreneurs qui on va avoir
besoin de soutien c'est ce sera là le
rôle de cette banque régionale
d'investissements il faut aussi
travailler justement sur les formations
c'est beaucoup changé en tant que ces
professionnels
beaucoup de mes jeunes lorsqu'ils sont
formés n'arrive pas à trouver d'emploi
pourquoi parce que l'offre ne correspond
pas à la demande
il faut justement nous sommes la
première région agricole
on ne forme pas ou très peu au métier
justement d'agro alimentaire
il faudrait justement que cette région
une soie nourricière que nos
agriculteurs puissent vivre
justement de leur activité et c'est ce
que nous accompagnerons avec audrey
pulvar pour justement faire un meilleur
équilibre vous l'avez dit nono espaces
ruraux souffre aussi de ce vraiment de
cette trempe tueur économie qui est pas
du tout dans leur faveur pendant cette
campagne la question de la sécurité est
aussi souvent revenu pas uniquement dans
cette région reprécise déjà pour les
électeurs que cette question de la
sécurité n'est pas une compétence
directe de la région néanmoins il existe
des leviers sur lesquels la région peut
agir dans les transports la
vidéosurveillance par exemple
est ce que la région doit doit favoriser
ce genre de dispositif intervenir plus
sécurisé et plus les lycées aussi par
exemple ça aussi c'est de la compétence
pour le coup de la région et bien en
tout cas nous sommes pour la
sécurisation aux abords des lycées je
voulais dit je suis enseignante on sait
très bien qu'il ya de nombreuses rixes
entre jeunes il faut sécuriser
on parle beaucoup de vidéosurveillance
mais il faut rappeler que pour qu'elle
soit efficiente il faut des personnes
derrière les caméras pour pouvoir
justement
et puis nous nous croyons que c'est
surtout la présence humaine qui va
permettre de pacifier notamment dans les
transports
vous avez 7 francilien sur dix on nous
dira que ils se sentent en insécurité
dans nos transports 100 % des femmes 100
% des femmes vont vous dire qu'elles ont
été soit victime soit se sont sentis en
insécurité dans les transports bien nous
disons que par exemple avec la gratuité
des transports nous concerterons les
personnes qui étaient justement dévolu à
l'eau contrôle des billets pour qu'il
soit plutôt des agents médiateurs pour
pacifier seulement juste la présence
quand vous êtes une femme et même un
public vulnérable
le fait d'avoir des personnes présentes
dans la rame vont vous rassurer parce
qu'il ya des stratégies d'évitement
aujourd'hui les femmes disparaissent des
transports en commun à partir d'une
certaine heure et nous ont dit que c'est
une pas une fatalité il faut sécuriser
nos transports à l'intérieur il faut
aussi effectivement mettre de la
sécurité aux abords de nos de nos lycées
mais surtout accompagné à l'intérieur
avec des infirmières scolaires avec d
orienter des psys coop pour pouvoir
justement les aider dans l'orientation
qui est aussi une des grandes de
compétences de notre région vous parlez
de médiation pas de sanction de la
sanction vous savez c'est là c'est le
rôle régalien de l'état
je pense que l'on ne doit pas se
substituer à ce rôle régalien
vous avez la police nationale vous avez
aussi une police ferroviaire qui existe
nous nous sommes là pour dire que la
région doit être dans ses compétences
avoir des transports plus sûr plus
fiable à leur rénové et qu'ils soient
justement en capacité de répondre aux
besoins et franciliennes et des francine
et une question plus large sur les
élections pour conclure cet entretien
politique vous êtes élu donc aussi aux
mureaux
donc une question plus sur le plan du
département plan plus local à la vie
politique les biennoises vous la
connaissez les listes de gauche par
contre n'ont pas vraiment fait l'union
pour la campagne des départementales
certains cantons présentent une seule
liste dans d'autres cantons il ya
beaucoup plus de divisions cette
campagne montre néanmoins que trouver
des candidats communs se mettre d'accord
sur ce programme sur un programme c'est
très difficile pour la gauche
aujourd'hui c'est pas que c'est très
difficile vous savez le problème c'est
que malheureusement sur ces élections
qu'elles soient régionales ou
départementales
beaucoup ont choisi de nationaliser le
débat c'est à dire que beaucoup le
voient comme une sorte de premier tour
des présidentielles pour pouvoir se
compter moi je trouve que c'est dommage
nous avons cherché au parti socialiste
et nous avons cherché avec audrey pulvar
à faire le rassemblement le plus large
possible parce que nous estimons que
seule la gauche peut être une
alternative à la politique qui est menée
notamment à la région si vous regardez
les sondages seule la gauche au second
tour rassembler pour à challenge et
valérie pécresse et donc changer cette
région de la même manière dans notre
département seule la gauche rassemblée
peut justement ramener un peu
d'opposition dans cet hémicycle qui
aujourd'hui et n'a qu'une seule couleur
c'est celle de de la droite
départementale
donc moi je le dis et je le répète je
suis vraiment désolé que nous aurions
nous aurons pas réussi à tomber d'accord
dans les endroits stratégiques où nous
pouvions emporter les cantons mais je
pense que la raison l'emportera au
second tour et que nous nous rangerons
toutes et tous derrière le candidat de
gauche qui serait arrivé en tête et sans
parler de la présidentielle il ya aussi
des législatives comme vous voyez les et
prochaine décidé chez ans pardon l'année
prochaine est-ce que vous pensez que la
gauche dès le début ne va pas chercher à
ce compte est justement est plutôt
chercher un programme d'alliance ou
est-ce que cette idée de gauche
plurielle du passé est définitivement
enterrée non je crois que les différents
entretiens notamment à l'initiative de
yannick jadot
dernièrement montre que nous avons tous
pleinement conscience que si nous ne
voulons pas nous retrouver dans cette
position mortifère d'avoir choisir entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen
il faut absolument que la gauche est un
candidat unique
ça va être difficile puisque jean luc
mélenchon répète à l'envi que quoi qu'il
en coûte
il sera il sera le candidat et qu'il
n'appelle cas se rassembler que derrière
sa personne je crois qu'il faut un
programme politique il faut un projet de
société une véritable alternative
ensuite viendra le temps de
l'incarnation moi ce que je veux c'est
une primaire des idées pour que la
gauche puisse imposer un autre
justement modèle de société avec plus de
justice sociale avec plus d'égalité mais
aussi avec de la transition écologique
j'espère que nous y arriverons parce que
si nous n'y arrivons pas ça veut dire
que nous serons dans la même position
qu'au etats unis c'est à dire que la
gauche finira par disparaître et que
nous n'aurons le choix qu'entre une
droite ultra libérale et une extrême
droite et ce n'est pas ce que je veux
pour mon pays merci demba diop est
revenu sur ce plateau engagé donc dans
cette campagne des régionales en île de
france aux côtés d'audrey pulvar premier
tour dimanche donc 20 juin nous voterons
à la fois pour les régionales et les
départementales 1 réalise résultats et
puis la première réaction à suivre dès
20h sur nos réseaux sociaux rendez-vous
aussi le lundi 21 juin sur tv 60 18 à 19
heures pour une édition spéciale avec
l'ensemble de la rédaction
à bientôt
[Musique]